I've heard many people
on the left sort of hyperventilating and
and about the consequences of this
decision for black Americans and for
racism
uh I mean this is uh I mean that's a
very uninformed fear to push I think
there's two things to say just right off
the bat one is nine states had already
banned affirmative action before this
ruling and I did not recall anyone you
know when I was applying to college in
2013 saying hey Coleman you know you're
a bright Black and Hispanic kid just
make sure you don't don't apply don't
bother applying to California or
Washington or all of the other these
other states Michigan because it's a
hellscape there for black kids no one
said that because no one even had that
fear and now there are people trying to
sort of uncover all the ways in which
it's been terrible terrible to be a
black Californian student for the past
25 years as a way of sort of justifying
that take you have also pointed out in
you have a phenomenal article uh that
you read at your sub stack about this
that is in our show notes and whatnot
but
um that we're also talking here about a
very elite phenomenon
um could you discuss that a little bit
and um you know just what what does that
mean in the context of college
admissions yeah so I I am a half black
half Hispanic Elite so when I when I
make these comments I come from a place
of uh of knowledge and love not of
denigration but the the policy we call
affirmative action is not a policy that
has anything to do with addressing the
problems of what used to be called the
black underclass the problems of black
poverty
um the legacy of of racism and and and
so forth It's a policy that affects
according to Princeton's sociologist
Thomas espenshade about one percent of
Black and Hispanic 18 year olds in any
given year the other 99 uh either don't
graduate high school to begin with OR
graduate high school but go to colleges
with with higher acceptance rates
um that don't practice affirmative
action so this some people want to frame
this as a decision about
access to higher education has nothing
to do with access to higher education
per se it has to do with the ease of
entrance
to a very select set of of ivy league
and Elite schools in general which have
a somewhat inflated sense of
self-importance to begin with for
instance if you look and again I speak
as someone who went to Colombia and yeah
so and Juilliard as well yeah which is a
totally different case but if you look
at the the colleges attended by the four
Fortune 500 CEOs in this country you see
very few Elite colleges there by and
large you see schools with like above 60
acceptance rates that wouldn't be
affected by this ruling and they also
they all somehow got good educations
there so I think we have to keep in
proportion what this case is really
about
and can we uh you know here is a slide
that um uh this is uh Joe Biden speaking
um uh saying you know affirmative action
is so misunderstood I want to be clear
make sure everybody is clear about what
the law has been and what it's not been
many people wrongly believe that
affirmative action allows unqualified
students to be admitted ahead of
qualified students this is not how
College admissions were and then um just
this is admit rates
at uh Harvard by racist race and
ethnicity and academic decile and what
this chart shows essentially is that in
uh the acceptance rate for an Asian
American in the top academic decile so
these are extremely you know High
performing students uh at Harvard had a
slightly lower rate than an
African-American applicant in the fourth
academic decile uh or the sixth in the
Hispanic so it it's not a question of
whether or not everybody is qualified or
unqualified but it does seem you know
clear and this certainly came out in the
case against Harvard that they were
diminishing the possibility of Asian
Americans to get in according to the way
that they would if kind of test scores
and the general profile uh was there
without a racial preference when you
look at something like that Coleman you
know what what's your response to that
you just said you're you know you're
Hispanic and African-American you
obviously have been you know killing it
yeah you know but like when you look at
that you know you know what's your
response to that
first of all
people have long defended affirmative
action by saying it's really just a
thumb on the scale it's used only as a
tiebreaker between otherwise identical
candidates you know I've always known
that that's just a lie or just
uninformed by the people who say it but
it does betray a sense that even
Defenders the of the policy are a little
bit uncomfortable defending the reality
of it they would wish it to be more of a
thumb on the scale thing but it's not
and we've had research that's shown that
for
I mean you know several decades actually
Thomas eschmanshade found it was the
equivalent of 450 sat points for an
Asian student relative to a black
student everything else held equal
um and and and just one more thing to
say about that
is is
um
actually sorry I just forgot the point I
was going to continue well yeah I
couldn't jump in the way Biden put it
was a bit of a word trick because he
made it hinge on
uh something to which there is no
definition qualified versus unqualified
you can't go and find data uh that is a
sort uh assorted by those categories in
order to sidestep the question of
whether better qualified applicants were
being turned away in favor of not as
well qualified applicants which is what
we can because statistics on and those
decile numbers uh were a good example of
many others uh so Biden makes a decision
that can't be verified about an
undefined concept uh because he'd rather
not talk about all the things that we do
know I think Walter you took that from
my head because that's precisely what I
wanted to say Coleman what happened in
places like California and Michigan was
there
you know was there a substantial and
persistent decline in you know the
number of blacks and Hispanics who were
admitted to you know the UC system or
the Cal State system things like that
and and if so is that is that a problem
and I just to add you know so that I
give you more questions than you could
possibly remember much less answer in a
single bound
um if that is if you know if it does
result in lower acceptance rates or
lower attendance rights among blacks and
Hispanics is it you know it's not is it
College where that kind of thing should
be addressed uh you know that kind of
disparity
so what happened in California is that
you know you see as you know is not a
college it's a whole set of colleges
yeah as as Cal State system some of
those colleges after affirmative action
was banned Black and Hispanic attendance
went down at other of those colleges it
went up so that the overall change in
attendance was nothing yeah which is
kind of great right and kind of exactly
what you'd expect
um and and there's a paper called did
the Skyfall uh the consequences of prop
209 which found that the graduation rate
among the post affirmative action class
was actually somewhat higher presumably
because people were better matched their
incoming credentials and preparedness
were better matched with the schools
they were they were attending
um one of the side effects of
affirmative action has been that you are
effectively sending that those Black and
Hispanic kids to be at the bottom of
those better schools
um which for some of them they I think
some of them will rise to the occasion
and find out that they really can uh
hold a candle to either all their
prepared peers but some of them can't
but half of U.S adults disapprove of
selective colleges considering race and
ethnicity
um a third approve it changes a little
bit blacks are more likely to approve
but it's still under half of blacks say
that should happen interestingly democ
people who are Democrats identify as
Democrats and lean Democrat 54 of them
approve of using racing ethnicity
you know on a certain level is this the
Supreme Court catching up to where the
country seems to be going well yeah I
mean
I think either every or almost almost
every time affirmative action has been
put to a state referendum including in
States liberal as California it's lost
um so it has long been a fairly
unpopular policy worth noting that
before 2020 Pew and Gallup asked these
questions in 2019 and back then even a
majority of black adults said that they
disapprove of the use of race in college
admissions
uh and and perhaps the
uh kind of culture of the past three
years has changed that for for black
Americans but nevertheless people and
you know what's really interesting here
to me
is that
back in 2019 when you asked the question
do you support affirmative action lots
of people would say yes majorities would
say yes but if you ask the same group of
people do you support the use of race
and college admissions they'd say no so
it's clear the framing of using that
euphemism affirmative action which if
you didn't know what it meant already
would never tell you what it meant
um lent the policy kind of an air of of
credibility that the actual substance
didn't have and that was an excerpt from
our reason live stream with Walter Olson
of the Cato Institute and Coleman Hughes
talking about recent Court decisions
dealing with affirmative action and
whether or not website operators had to
serve gay couples if you want to see
another excerpt go here if you want to
see the full thing and you should go
here